hi my name is Adam Kosh from the Android
developer relations team at Google today
I wanted to talk to you about the new
SMS api's in android 4.4 kitkat
so let's jump right in starting with
Android 4.4 KitKat there's the new
concept of a default SMS application
only the default SMS application can
write directly to the system content
provider other apps that try and riot
will fail silently of course any app can
still read from the system content
provider as long as they have the
correct permission so you might be
thinking why do we need this new concept
of a default SMS app in previous
versions of Android you could already
assign some of the SMS intents to any
application the difference is that app
had no unique privileges over any other
app on the system with the new default
SMS app selection that app will now have
additional privileges and be guaranteed
to get every single message another app
cannot abort the delivery of the SMS or
interrupt that flow this helps to
increase reliability additionally no
other app can delete or alter messages
out from underneath the default app
which helps to decrease complexity
within the default SMS app this combined
with the fact that some of the
previously private ap is in earlier
versions of Android and now public means
that third-party SMS apps are supported
first-class citizens of the Android
system
so let's talk about implementation to be
legible as the default SMS app you must
support some specific capabilities in
your Android manifest you have to define
two receivers to handle the receiving of
sms's and MMS a--'s you can see here
that the actions are SMS deliver and WAP
Push deliver they also note that these
receivers require an additional
permission on the actual receiver
additionally you have to define an
activity a UI that can handle creation
of new sms's so here we've got a
composed SMS activity this might be
triggered say from the system people app
when you go and create a new SMS to a
particular contact and lastly you also
need a service that can also respond to
creating and sending new sms's this is
used by the system when a phone call
comes in and if you can't take it you
can quickly swipe up to send an SMS in
the background to the person saying the
reason why you can't actually take that
call once you've to finally think all of
these things you'll be illegible to show
up in a new system dialogue that lets
you choose the default SMS app
additionally you can also display a
dialog that lets the user switch to your
application as the default SMS app and
I'll show you how to do that shortly
after this one thing worth noting is
that you still need to declare the same
application web permissions that you
always did to access SMS functionality
things like write SMS read SMS send SMS
receive SMS and receive MMS some of the
previous slides you will have seen the
two receivers we defined have two new
KitKat delivery actions SMS deliver
action and WEP push deliver action these
only get delivered to the default SMS
application but in previous versions of
Android there was actually a private API
that allowed you to also receive these
sms's these actions were SMS received
action and
the push received action and these still
exist in KitKat and are actually now
public and applications can still listen
to them as they did before to
distinguish the difference between these
two think of SMS received action as the
system has received an SMS whereas the
SMS deliver action says the system is
delivering your app and SMS because you
are the default SMS app so let's talk
about some message receiver best
practices for apps that are not looking
to become the default they should just
carry on as normal using the message
received actions these are the ones that
as I mentioned were private before
KitKat but are now public in KitKat the
apps that do want to become the default
they should probably be listening to
both the message received and the new
SMS delivered ones so that means that
when they're running on KitKat they
should really disable the one that's not
being used the message received actions
to do that they should use the package
manager set component enabled setting
method that way they can disable these
and they won't be using unnecessary
resources and be triggered as new SMS
has come in another approach to handling
them is to use boolean resource files to
automatically enable and disable the
receivers based on platform version
really the difference between these two
is that set component enabled setting is
a little more flexible you can choose
within code when you want to change it
whereas the boolean resource is simpler
that less flexible so let's quickly look
at how you would implement the boolean
method you see we've created two boolean
XML files in our resource directories
one under the default resurrector e with
two values has KitKat and pre key cat
we've additionally created another one
in values dash V 19 which means any
devices running on Android 4.4 KitKat or
above will automatically load this
resource file instead and you can see
we've set has kicked cats are true and
pre-kick cats are false then in our
Android manifest file in our receiver
declarations we assign this boolean to
the Android enabled attribute
this has the effect that on certain
versions of Android one will be enabled
and the other disabled and the reverse
on the newer platforms if you haven't
seen this technique before follow the
link here on the right or the QR code to
get more information
another new API in KitKat is the ability
to check which is the default SMS
application using the telephony SMS get
default SMS package method you can see
we're checking to see if we're running
on KitKat or above and then we're going
to use that method to work out if we're
currently the default SMS application
you can then call this in your own
resume of your key activities hide and
show certain layouts as appropriate and
also enable and disable certain
functionality as appropriate for example
you may not want to allow sending SMS as
if you are not currently the default SMS
application you can also open a system
dialog to us user if they would like to
switch the default SMS application to be
yours to do this use a new intent action
action change default along with an
extra-extra package name to pass your
package name to another activity which
opens a system dialog that looks
something like this that I showed you
before as soon as the user clicks yes
your application will now be the default
your previous activity will get a call
to unreserve and it can adjust its
layouts and functionality as needed
lastly some additional notes messages
can still be sent by any application
using the existing SMS Manager api's
assuming of course they hold the ascend
SMS permission however for apps other
than the selected default the system
writes all outgoing SMS messages to the
system provider automatically it won't
however write outgoing MMS this is
particularly important for auxiliary SMS
apps that may work alongside another app
which is the default one thing worth
noting though these auxilary apps will
no longer be able to write to the system
content provider themselves so they
won't be able to do things like deleting
messages or marking messages as read or
unread
on the flipside the default SMS
application is responsible for writing
its outgoing messages to the system
provider
lastly SMS back up apps will need to
temporarily become the default when
restoring messages so that they can
write correctly to the system content
provider for additional reference to the
new SMS API CIN KitKat see the Android
developer blog where we have additional
information posted up you can follow
this link or this QR code on the right
side of the screen
will actually be posting some sample
code up and linking to it in the
description of this video and also on
the blog post thanks for tuning in to
this dev byte